look at that yeah did you know candle  Flames conduct electricity better than  air that is because there are ions in  the flame positively and negatively  charged particles resulting from the  combustion process it's kind of a plasma  and you can see that the flame has two  separate pieces to it now one is going  towards the negative plate and those  would be the positive ions and the  negative ions will be going towards a  positively charged plate these two  plates are charged up to 20 000 volts  which in air can make a two centimeter  spark but through the candle flame it  can make a much larger spark because of  those ions there are even ions in the  Smoke which is why it separates into two  streams positive charges go to the  negative plate and negative charges to  the positive plate